you've shot a number of different
projects if someone has actually never
seen anything you've done before what is
the first thing you'd like them watching
and why a good question I I have to say
I think uh Belfast is one of my favorite
films I've made so I'd say well we
started what I consider maybe my best
work and then work your way down yeah
that that turned out okay you know
um uh so I definitely I spoke to Ben
recently for the meg2 and he sounded
like he had such a blast and he told me
a great story about what why you wanted
to work with you how much fun did you
have making the Meg sequel oh it was an
absolute plus Mega Ben is a fantastic
fantastic filmmaker and he was the
reason why I wanted to participate I've
always loved his films and um he's a a a
a true filmmaker it was a joy to make
with him yeah I also loved the shot you
guys did of uh the inside of the shark
biting down
um with the people coming into the mouth
I made Ben break down how you guys shot
that
he's got a great sense of Terror and a
great sense of humor
um jumping into uh uh one so you and
Kenneth started working together on
sleuth and you couldn't have known when
you made that project that it was going
to lead to this collaboration of I think
seven movies so what when did you my bad
so when did you realize
um when you were making sleuth oh wait
maybe he really likes me for this job oh
no
Ken is always with not just with me but
with everyone he's very uh generous with
his uh he's a generous Soul so he's
generous with his compliments
um uh he's genuinely appreciative of of
every department and every collaborator
he's with
um and that I think is quite infectious
there's a there's a
um an old-fashioned chivalry that
Kenneth uh has that
um it just it makes you want to be the
best you you know on on set to just want
to behave in a in a in a polite manner
in a professional manner and to just
work with passion and um that's what I
got in in the first collaboration with
Ken and that's what I got on the last
collaboration I basically look at every
film as if it's the first and last film
I will do with any director it doesn't
matter whether it's someone I've worked
with a lot and certainly with with and I
kind of feel like
you have to just not take the
relationship for granted and be a great
communicator communication is the best
form of of of kind of both uh
collaboration and friendship what were
actually some of the unique challenges
you ran into on uh making a haunting
versus say the the first two of the in
the trilogy well I think one of the
things about Haunting in Venice is if
it's a far more intimate story
um one of the things that uh
characteristic of a Christie novel and a
story
um uh she she lived and traveled in a
time when travel was rare and and
expensive and and and she basically made
her readers uh travel the world with her
and subsequently within that travel and
and and what that does I think is just
opens those receptors when you read
those kinds of stories you're kind of
hit or in this adventure and all of a
sudden she just takes it all the way
back down to this very Elemental human
story about The Human Condition You know
it's it's
um
it's a dramatic moment a cathetic moment
of a crime and and you live through the
crime and punishment in her writing and
and and you have a cathartic moment at
the end I think in the this particular
case which is a lesser known story it's
it's the the location although extremely
important in our case
um uh was not so much about the opening
The receptors of travel and openness
Etc and making you kind of like in a way
um the exuberance of life then brought
down to these base levels you're already
in a in a kind of dark post-war period
where um things are already kind of that
there's none of that exuberance to begin
with so it becomes a different type of a
story and it becomes a story
um that's intimately about the human
condition and it becomes a horror story
in that the crime committed is a
incomprehensibly terrible crime and it
haunts both our protagonist puero it
haunts the people involved around it
and and ultimately haunts the audience
that experience
um uh this tragedy and uh this crime one
of the things is the first two films in
the trilogy you shot on 70 millimeter
and this film you shot digitally uh can
you talk about why you switched to
digital for this film there were a lot
of photographic characteristics that we
wanted to maintain
um in the in in in the poro films one
was a certain kind of uh Clarity uh the
other is a sense of depth of field now
we wanted to shoot this in a very dark
way and both film and digital so far has
been limited uh not much more than the
800 ASA range and when you wanted to
shoot a film in low light levels with
Candlelight and authentic lighting
fixtures of a particular time period you
usually I think in the past from the
days of Barry Linden onwards even to
modern day films
you'd have to rely on using
um the a faster lens and by using a a
faster lens and an f-stop of say T1
famously on Barry Linden or you know 1.4
um on on on most low low light level
films you have very little depth of
field and that depth of field comes into
play where you only see one iron focus
at any one given time and you're
constantly making decisions in camera
about which are you going to focus on
one of the things that is I think makes
the intimacy of the portrait show that
we have used on previous pyro films is
that we work at a slightly higher depth
of field
um than most uh uh films
um T4 not Citizen Kane levels but just
enough for the face and its features are
all in focus
um so we wanted to shoot with
um a uh a large format lens uh camera
system that was in the highest
sensitivity to light and that was the
Sony Venice II
um and uh those photographic elements
were more important than the analog
versus digital that we were able to
shoot at low light levels but with a uh
uh a decent or a preferred depth of
field and
um those were the the choices behind
shoetic this with
um with the the a digital camera I
always wonder I mean listen I I think
Kubrick's a God and you know the films
that he's made are so incredible and I
just always think about what would he
have done being able to use digital
cameras and would he have embraced them
or would he have shunned them the way
for example Nolan likes to shoot
everything on film you know any you know
what I mean it's uh because the artistic
view of so many more choices when you're
shooting digital like you just said you
can shoot in these crazy low-light
situations for example I think he used
natural you know just like candlelights
to light certain things yes and but like
I said I think it's not just that it's
that there were there are other
photographic attributes I mean I can't
speak for cubic he he had such an
individual approach he I think he did
everything
um
uh as as was kind of as he saw fit in a
way and I I feel like I don't I wouldn't
like to be restricted
um by kind of being put into a a this
idea that I would only use one camera or
one set of lenses I've I've changed
systems and lenses according to
um the kind of projects needs and and
and my own interpretation at all time
and I think that's I think that
that's important that you don't you
don't give
um
the important aspect of things and this
is we we have to think in a way uh
Anthony Dodd mantle and
um
you know for that kind of celebration of
whatever camera you know
creates that intimate story to me he has
done great things in that that he should
be praised for that because he has
pushed for and he's a great
analog film cinematographer as well and
I think if you're as well versed as
someone like Anthony then you're
groundbreaking in that you're using
different formats and he has in in many
ways liberated uh filmmaking from those
kind of dogmas uh one of the things is
uh uh you guys shot on a lot of
practical sets and then you went to
Venice for the exteriors
um what was that like uh coming up with
uh you know like a shooting on set and
then going to exteriors do you prefer
something like that or would you rather
do the exteriors first and then do the
interior or does that not make a
difference in in our particular case
because we shot linearly in a way sorry
wise over kind of a morning through to
an afternoon and night and then
um it really didn't make a difference we
were we we really wanted to shoot things
in
the majority of the story happens
chronologically
in terms of how we shot it on stage
anyway so I think more for us it would
be the uh and it's a big deal for
Kenneth is to be able to shoot
chronologically
um that keeps you in rhythm with the
story uh as you're progressing in a way
and
um it it didn't interrupt our filmmaking
in in in a great deal I'd say before I
run out of time with you I'm also a huge
fan of Tim Burton and I wanted to know
uh what it was like getting the phone
call from him to possibly shoot a sequel
that I'm very excited for well it was a
it's a dream project and um what I'm
very proud of uh we still haven't
finished but um
um hopefully we we kind of have have
done something special there as well and
and
um and yes um
I can't wait for that to uh to be ready
as well that would be my what so that's
you've got two two films for Halloween
this year and next year to look forward
to that I've shot
um exactly one of the things though
about the first film is it's so great
the way it was shot using practical
everything and I'm just curious before
you start on a sequel to that film are
you re-watching the first one to sort of
see what you know what I mean because I
I heard you guys are doing a lot of the
same stuff that was done on the first
film yes we certainly are shooting
things in camera
um and for real and uh that was that's
part of the charm I mean he was a great
filmmaker in that respect and
um
although he's quite a bit he's he's both
a Visionary and a very classical
filmmaker at the same time
um and that was we did a lot of that on
Haunting in Venice as well what you see
in the film is is very much in camera
um
so uh yes uh that's that's in a way I I
think I enjoyed both that that aspect of
the filmmaking of these last two films
I've made I think I've enjoyed immensely
that Reliance on uh practical techniques
um and and I think you get a very very
different
um uh uh kind of performance out of
actors and you get a very when when
things are done in camera
and I think you get a very different
audience
um uh reaction out of in-camera effects
oh those are things for example are far
more important than whether something is
digital or analog it's the authenticity
of the experience I think of it is often
um kind of the most uh impactful uh
aspect of filmmaking I I could not agree
with you more
um when I see something that's done on
green screen it it's uh let's just say
it takes me out and when it looks like
someone's standing in an actual building
you know on and because the sets that
you guys built for haunting are you know
they're great and it just adds so much
yeah
on that note I got to stop with you I'm
just gonna say I am a fan of your work
thank you for giving me your time and uh
I hope the film's a huge hit
thank you Steve it's lovely talking to
you
um have a fantastic day good luck with
the rest of your arrest speed dating
thank you